you know what i did try and do one time
with it okay so um so
you know how like um like corner stores
they don't really have like the super
ultra advanced labeling price level
thing they just kind of have like those
little cheap plastic paper stickers
yeah yeah yeah like the orange ones they
would put like a pound or 50 pence at
one time i thought like
i just had like a gigabrain thought
actually i'm gonna swap them
i'm gonna swap the labels yeah i really
want this thing but i don't have enough
i think i'm like one pound it's one
pound fifty i'm like i'm gonna change
the label
and i was like heart was [ __ ] racing
going up to the stand like
to the to the the tail i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] play cool play cool play cool
and then so i'm you know you're scanning
them and then i'm like and then
as he's scanning them i realized i'm
like wait you just scanned it and
it doesn't [ __ ] matter what the label
says because the [ __ ] bar code
[Music]
he was like oh it's got the wrong label
on it like oh does it does it
wow i never noticed thanks for pointing
that out
i think the worst thing i've ever done
is um
like you know when uh in england you
know when they introduced the
self-service machines
which is the closest thing i think
england's got got into a trash system
yeah right and uh on top of this england
within within our lifetime england has
added
the plastic bag tax which wasn't always
there normally you could take as many
plastic bags as you wanted um
normally you could take as many plastic
bags as you wanted uh but
like i think how many years ago where
they introduced the five p
tax for like in order to take five six
years ago yeah like five six years ago
um and i remember this you know this
this one time um
it was it was in a tescos or something
and i had like
i didn't have my card on me because i
just like gone out the house so i just
had like
like change in my pocket and it i i came
up to the till
and it was self-service and it went up
to the exact
change of my shopping right
but i hadn't bought the plastic bag yet
so i was just like do i put everything
back
bro if i was working yeah i'd feel like
bro yeah yeah you're not new for having
the perfect amount yeah
yeah so i was just like do i put
everything back run back home which is
only five minutes away and come back
with
like with a tenner or like uh like my
card or something to buy this
or do i just press the i have one i have
paid for one bag
no no do i just press the zero bag
option
and i i i i like i like look around i
start like [ __ ] sweating because i'm
just like i'm a good asian boy i've
never broken the law in my life but i'm
just like
check this check the security camera i
just like check the store clock
time [ __ ] stops you know you don't
[ __ ] put the hood over yeah
you know when you feel like you've got a
[ __ ] spotlight on you and i'm just
like
all right i'm just [ __ ] lagging
yeah yes and now that's on camera so yes
oh my god
i'm a criminal guy absolutely criminal
gear to be fair with that one i think
i'd paid my card a bunch and i'd
forgotten to put the plastic bag and
they're literally right there
and i paid my card and i had no cash on
me i'm like i'm not getting my card out
oh yeah
so i'll just take one they didn't give a
[ __ ] they never gave a [ __ ] he's gone
sweating and i'm just connection
because i'm i'm pretty sure i've
accidentally pressed
zero bags when i've taken one or two
bags like so many times
it's it's gone it's the conscious choice
and i it's that i consciously made that
choice
it's the confident press of the body
between manslaughter and murder guys
i think that's why the trust is